hello I'm President Snow Dwyer welcoming  you to the games journalism hungry games  no maximum games journalism is dying  which is why every year we take tributes  to ensure that the strong will survive  this year's districts have paid tribute  they are from IGN Gregory Miller Brian  all tarnished Ashby on from giant bomb  Jeffrey Gusman Daniel right you'll each  be from rev3games para la nicholas  robinson from ScrewAttack craig schist  imiss Sean Boland from twitch TV  Jonathan carnage Justin Flynn and from  gamespot Christopher waters merican town  advantage tributes will battle in both  team and solo fights of various couch  competitive games until a single  district is left the winner takes home  the pride of the industry plus a really  [ __ ] trophy we made in enough to move  it's really so calm and support your  tributes 1230 on friday at PAX Prime  Sasquatch theater shout scream and may  the vods be ever in  you